We know that there are going to be N source elements,
and we're going to have the same N destination elements.
So for any particular source element, say X here,
we must fetch that source element for each individual computation for every destination element,
and for a particular destination element,
we know that we have to fetch the parameters for each individual source element.
So overall we have to fetch each element N times as the source and N times as the destination,
or if we assume that an object does not exert any force on itself,
then we'd fetch each element N minus 1 for each of the source or destination.
The answer should be either 2N or 2N minus 2 times; This is quite expensive.
We'd really like to organize the computation in such a way that we consume less global memory bandwidth,
and we're going to try to do this by storing and reusing some of these memory fetches,
and in particular, we'd like to be able to take advantage of the GPU's ability
to share data between neighboring threads.